hmm another rat but those eyes a
starving wolf before I kill you tell me
your name tell me your name
[Music]
no name to give you should know me are
all the same you die nameless with no
one to mourn you however your left eye a
prosthetic shinobi arm
it reminds me of the reason he laughs is
that once there was another with a
similar name sekito the one arm to ranga
Tang it's it a one-armed dwarf leg which
means circular that is what I shall name
you words have meaning but names have
power and yours is tied to another I
brought some sake don't mind if I do
oh is it not to your liking
no it's damn good but it does make my
old wounds baked your left arm yes and
this sucker was a favorite of the man
who cut it off
who was Lord ishy Mishy why he did it
for my sick I was on the verge of being
consumed consumed by what Shura well
whether you believe me or not that's for
you to decide but you do well to be
where shuras shadow Shura is a sort of
demon a manifestation of hatred that can
appear in those who kill excessively
although ition killed many polishing his
skills and the blood of his enemies he
did not succumb to sugar why well
because after every enemy he killed he
performed the breath of nature expelling
both regret and reaffirming his Corps
shinobi
however in
Herot the Karma of those they've killed
and they become physically burdened with
regrets as a result they see it in your
eyes to the shadow of Shura hmm give me
cause and I will kill you it would do
you well to remember that
to understand what set the sculptor on
his path to shooter we look to his past
way back when he was still known as the
bounding monkey of the sunken valley I
trained in the techniques of the shinobi
in the valley where the monkeys dwelled
by herself no there were two of us we
were rogue shinobi there was no proper
master for the likes of us that's why we
went to the valley to run to jump to
clash swords where one slip would mean
your doom that was how we trained we
came to move exactly as monkeys did
after a time I drink this monkey booze
whenever I tired of training and I'd
listened to the howl of my partners
whistling finger while I drank how it
was from that unique ring whistling
through that ring would fill the valley
with a somber melody strangely enough I
enjoyed that sound I listened to it so
often her cry could once be heard all
along the waterfront of the sunken
valley as she whistled through this ring
that could also send beasts wild and it
was this same ring that was
unfortunately found in the belly of such
a beast and it's a sound that the
sculptor will recall forever
to think it was in the belly of an ape
I'm sure it'll play a somber but
enjoyable to make sure you use it well
perhaps it was the loss of his training
partner that set him on the path to
shura after all it's implied that there
was more between them but after a sheen
severed shuras arm
the flames of hatred receded and
sculptor regained control and after Seki
joe's defeat his tires to the ash in a
deepened for a sheen had this charm
about him he had a way of turning his
enemies into compare treants especially
those he respected for their battle
prowess for there were still many
battles to be won after one such battle
sekito found a young girl on the
battlefield she was staring up at him so
intently that he felt he had to give up
this rice ball that he was eating when I
was young I stood alone in the aftermath
of a battlefield I was alone and staring
dumbfounded I could do nothing neither
cry nor even get angry complete shock
and then there was a monkey eating a
rice ball a monkey maybe an ape maybe
either way he made it look so delicious
I remember being angry at that but then
then he gave me the rice ball it tasted
so good what a kind monkey yes
he was a very kind monkey after this
Emma threw herself into medical work
with her new mentor Dogen who was a
doctor of incredible ability after that
well a while later a Sheena became a
dangerous place for the both of us
around then Dogen adopted her as his
daughter i suppose it didn't really
matter where she ended up one thing's
for sure she's happier for the fact she
wasn't raised by a shinobi our story is
testament to that fact for we too were
found on a battlefield by a shinobi he
was a cunning owl who would go on to use
us to deny the self and to leave us
nameless save for being known as a loyal
wolf yet we were saved once more in a
sort of rebirth where our life became
indebted to another this time not to a
cunning owl but to a kind monkey instead
and through him to the man who crafted
his left arm about lady Emma's father
doe gedan he was an extraordinary doctor
he was also very well versed in
mechanisms and devices better put he was
obsessed with mechanisms to the point
that it affected his health it didn't
take much else seriously but I owed in
my life and we could say that you owe
him your life as well what do you mean
when I lost my left arm
Dogen created that thing which has now
become your left arm the first version
was a complete failure didn't work at
all so he remade it then he remade it
again and again countless time
what he told me I needed to practice
with the prosthetic in order to use it
properly so Emma would pester me into
carving her spinning tops and other toys
after much training of that sort it came
to be called a shinobi thing in other
words that prosthetic arm is doggins
legacy his legacy so much time has
passed while I have abandoned my shinobi
ways that alone I could not bear to
abandon I'd never have believed that one
such as myself would save another who'd
lost their arm like you have I'm sure it
is fate but all of these people all of
the asana lead back to Ishii
there is something I'd like to ask you
of course who trained you to fight with
a blade how blade I am a doctor
yes but who lured oisin but I only have
a passing interest I did not believe
your skill counts as a mere passing
interest
why did you learn well not to kill
people
what do you mean no I don't have the
slightest desire to kill anyone it's
just
I would want to kill a demon if one were
to appear a demon don't take me
seriously it was only a joke as he sheen
would say the buns the tiles are so
deeply amusing and we are tired to
sekito who is a constant warning of what
a shinobi can become because once it's
touched you Shura never really leaves
war is on the horizon a dreadful one at
that the Dead will rise as mountains and
the hate will flow like an inferno
it will give birth to a demon I'm
certain of it
the interior ministry tried and they
failed to take action at once before but
now they're ready they know its people
they know their weaknesses they know the
land and this time they will set it
ablaze orangutan the central forces are
here are they now they never change the
thieving ways are the flames still
burning Emma the answer to that isn't
going to change I could carve Buddha
idols for all eternity
and the flames of hatred would still
rage on the most I can do is keep them
in check orangutan what is it if the
time ever comes then I'll
I have ordered a carve goodbye listen
what you'll be the one to kill me what
are you talking about
don't play the fool to make her after
kill me I don't think I could bear it
please but if you don't have Kuro
strength of purpose to guide you and if
you kill for the sake of power like
elders then we too can get lost
[Music]
no your
[Music]
but it doesn't have to be this way or if
you learn from the sculptors mistakes
and fight for kuru and not for hatred
then you may become one who prevents
Shura from taking root in the world all
it takes is to remember who we are you
know don't you you know who the
one-armed demon was before yes if you're
like me and you find seculars Eastern
philosophies fascinating then I'd like
to put you onto this little audio book
that I read last year and it's one that
really changed the way I experience the
world this is the little audio book of a
key guy brought to you by audible Ikki
guy is a Japanese word for describing
the pleasures and meanings of life the
word literally consists of a key to live
and guy reason so a key guy is about
finding joy in the little things whether
it's sipping a cup of coffee in the
morning or spying a ray of sunshine
through the trees or even just working
efficiently at a task and after you
practice this mentality for a little
while you sort of stop looking for
external sources of gratification which
allows you to better focus on and to
enjoy the task at hand even if it is
just work or performing your daily
chores these things actually become
enjoyable you can start the new year
learning about a key guy today with a
30-day audible trial choose one audio
book and two audible originals
absolutely free just visit audible.com
slash party video or text fighting video
- 500 500 everything I recommend to you
guys is something i've personally
listened to and we all share a lot
of the same interests here so suggest me
some audiobooks as well I listen to them
a lot in my downtime so if you think you
have a few hours that you could fill
with an audiobook visit audible.com
slash body video or text body video to
500 500 and let me know what are you
listening to but as always guys thank
you for watching and I'll see you soon